(soft music)
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] I feel like I missed the memo
of cute, pantsuit outfit today.
Like, I was like "Wait, what?
Y'all look so adorable".
Nice to see you.
- Nice to see you too.
- [Kelly] You know each other, right?
- Yes, we're besties.
- Yeah, I taught her how to ski.
(audience laughs)
- I am amazing.
So wait, you were skiing
in Iceland this summer
and this video is amazing
for a couple reasons,
but what's going on here?
- [Lindsey] That is a
helicopter picking me up,
or dropping me off at about
one o'clock in the morning.
At that time of year, the sun doesn't set.
So, it was crazy.
One of the most crazy
experiences of my life.
Helicopter skiing at one in the morning.
(Lindsey chuckles)
- I love how different
people can be, you know?
(audience laughs)
Isn't that awesome? There's
like, room for all of us.
Because I'm just like, if
one of my girls was like,
"You know what I'm gonna do,
and you should do it with me,
is wake up at midnight
and then go skiing".
Getting dropped off by a
helicopter, which in those winds,
like a helicopter can't be
like, your safest route.
- [Lindsey] No, it's probably not.
I mean, you know, a trail lift
would be probably, more safe.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Lindsey] But yeah, it's,
skiing is dangerous enough as it is.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Add, you know...
- Yeah.
- I would...
- Injury on that one, but...
- I would like to interrupt and say that
her heliskiing is probably safer
than with her downhill skiing.
Because that's what's dangerous.
You know, when she was
skiing at that, like,
at that pace, racing,
that's when you can really hurt yourself.
That's probably nothing compared to that.
- [Lindsey] She has a point.
- But also, but, great,
so both are so crazy.
But like, you're going
through forests, right?
Like when you get dropped off...
- No, there was, we're
above the tree line,
so there was no, there
were no trees at all.
- Like on your whole path down?
- Nope.
- Oh.
- Just rocks, so avoid the rocks.
(audience laughs)
Avoid the rocks.
- Just rocks.
- Yeah, just a couple.
(Lindsey chuckles)
- Those are handy.
- Yeah.
- Okay, wait, you had
such a great vacation.
That's awesome.
Have you been heliskiing?
Have you ever jumped out?
- I have, I have.
- You have?
- [Lindsey] Yeah, that's
why we're besties.
- [Chelsea] Yeah, we're friends, we're,
we actually haven't skied
together yet, though.
But we will, we will ski together.
- [Lindsey] Eventually, if
she's never, not on tour.
- [Kelly] You've jumped
out of a helicopter?
- [Chelsea] Well, we'll do it this winter.
We're gonna go in Park City.
- Okay, if you call me to
hang out, I will be busy.
(Kelly laughs)
It's like, no you won't, but if you did...
- You can apres ski.
- You can go tubing,
while we're heliskiing.
We'll drive you down
and you'll be in a tube.
- [Kelly] I don't even like,
like on my ranch, in Montana, you can tube
and you can ski, there's like
pretty-high slopes there.
But I am terrified of even tubing.
- Risk is fun.
- [Kelly] It is for some.
(Lindsey chuckles)
It is.
And some of us are so good with average.
(Lindsey laughs)
So wait, so you've got a book out now.
This is awesome.
So, it's called, "Rise".
So, what, it's your story, my story.
So, why did you wanna do this?
- [Lindsey] You know, I
retired from ski racing
and it was, I think
really therapeutic for me
to kind of look back at my life.
And I really wanted to share some
of the lessons that I've
learned, the experiences
and I've had a lot of injuries,
a lot of personal struggles.
So, you know, I again, I've learned a lot
and I, I just wanted to inspire my fans
to be their best selves.
Just like, I learned
how to be in my career.
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.
(audience applauds)
You, you recently lost your mama
and this book is dedicated to her.
So how did she, how did she inspire it?
- Yeah, I mean my mom has
been a huge inspiration
in my life.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah, and I, you know,
dedicated the book to her
when I found out she had ALS
and I was gonna dedicate
it to her anyways.
But, she died only a few weeks ago
and you know, she had a stroke
when she gave birth to me.
She's faced so many obstacles in her life
and it really gave me a
perspective on my life
and how I approach it and you know,
whenever I have a bad
day, I looked at my mom
and I said, "Well she has a
positive attitude, why can't I?"
So, she was such an inspiration
to me and it's been hard.
- [Kelly] It's a really
beautiful thing though,
to know that you've had that.
Like, not everybody
gets that right in life.
It's such a hard thing to grieve,
but just to know, it's
such a beautiful thing too,
to have had a mom that
had that kind of impact
that you do something cool like this
and dedicate it and know that's a reason,
one of the main reasons
why you got where you are.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] It's so, really cool, beautiful.
Well Lindsey, one thing that you've had
to recover from, is a ski injury in 2013.
So, it led to insomnia?
- Yeah, so I mean, I've,
I had a lot of obstacles in my life,
but you know, having so many surgeries,
you know, I was laying in,
in my bed and you know,
I know as an athlete you
need sleep to recover.
Everyone knows that.
And, and I just struggled so much
after my surgeries to sleep and you know,
it's, I approached it as I
approached everything else,
you know, how do I find a solution?
And I didn't really realize
that it was actually
insomnia until much later.
But I, you know, tried a lot of things
and I was just so thankful
that I found a solution.
You know, I talked to my
doctor and Quviviq is,
you know, a new medication that I've found
and I'm very thankful for.
Especially now, you know, with everything
that's going on in my life,
sometimes, I just have a hard
time shutting off my mind
and you know, everyone
thinks that, you know,
not sleeping is just kind
of normal and you know,
hey, I only sleep four hours a night.
That's not, not normal, we need sleep...
- That's because of society,
yeah, we don't sleep enough.
We are always going and going and going.
- Yeah.
- To get ahead you must keep
going, like that kind of thing.
- So, like one box, you
know, checked off my list
of things that I don't have
to worry about anymore.
- Insomnia sucks, I used, I
used to suffer from that too.
And on tour it's hard,
because especially if you
get done with like a big,
race thing and, and,
and I would get done with a performance.
Like, you'd get done and
your body is so amped up
that it's really hard to come down.
- [Lindsey] Yeah.
- Like from that adrenaline rush.
- Yeah, the adrenaline rush is hard to...
- Yeah.
- So, I can't even imagine
at the speeds you were going
and like, you know,
near death experiences.
So, that would be hard to come down from.
I'm glad you found something.
- Yeah, thank you.
- [Kelly] Because man,
when you don't get sleep,
I'm a, I'm not likable.